out with the old and in with the new
that's the idea behind one congressman's
plan to drop House and Senate members
salaries to just one dollar a year after
twelve years of service Florida
congressman Francis Rooney believes the
legislation will bring fresh ideas make
lawmakers more independent joins me now
to discuss this could even congressman
term limits without going through the
constitutional amendments everybody
knows that it's gonna be very difficult
if not impossible to admit the
Constitution yet there are 12 bills up
just to do that with 90 sponsors now we
can find out if those folks want to fish
or cut bait why are you doing this I'm
doing this because I believe term limits
are important I believe the citizen
legislature principle of Cincinnatus and
Thomas Jefferson or what are important
to our country important values to our
country I think that rotating out more
legislators would keep things fresh
getting more new ideas keep people
responsive to the people all right you
write that you have seven co-sponsors
congressman introduced this Thomas
Jefferson Public Service Act it means
effectively putting term limits in place
without amending the Constitution
reducing the salary of an elected member
of Congress to one dollar a year after
they serve six consecutive terms in the
house or two consecutive terms in the
Senate
here's bill Nelson from Florida about
working hard I am now the ranking
Democrat and if we get the majority will
be the chairman
it takes time to work up through the
seniority system so I would think that
that's particularly important to Florida
so what about that argument that it
takes a while to know how to get around
this place and maybe this is not this
artificial cap is not the right cap well
first I kind of resent the elitist
paternalism that Senator Nelson and the
brookings industry in Institutes of
these people say that that the people
that are elected by the people can't
operate effectively for the people who
elected them that's what our country is
built on is an elector electoral
republic so I think that we should put
our trust in the people and the people
that get elected in the in seniority at
a time of globalization technology
Twitter Facebook I mean come on this
seniority is an anachronism all right
but what do you say to the people who
look at your bill and say okay so you
are enabling the rich people to all run
because they could go with a $1 a year
and it's all rich people who are running
for Congress and Senate it's a logical
point but what I believe and I believe
this very firmly that were the culture
of the citizen legislature to take
effect
twelve years over ninety ninety nine
percent of the legislators are doing the
12 years and leaving on to some other
job anybody any old rich guy that or
glady that want to stay on and do that
is going to be such an outlier that they
would be roundly and vigorously opposed
and quite frankly should be here's
something from your leadership in the
House and the Senate on this issue
I've watched states do it some it failed
that and some it worked at I think the
most important term limit you have is at
the ballot box and we've got to show
that we can actually work and solve the
problems I would say we have term limits
now they're called elections and it will
not be on the agenda in the Sun your
reaction well that's why 86% of the
American people want them and I'm a
business guy so I figure if 86 percent
of my customers want something my job is
to figure out how to get it for them so
the prospects of moving this forward
what do you think they are well I don't
know we're gonna find out if people
really want to fish or cut bait I mean
there are 90 co-sponsors on the 12 term
limit by amendment bills the freedom
caucus guys a lot of them have talked
about term limits and several of them
are my co-sponsors a lot of freshmen
have talked about term limits bills some
of them are my co-sponsors and then
there's something called a term limb
a caucus let's see what they want to do
and you think that this bill if it
passed could get through legally yeah
yeah the bill people in the house
researched it and said then Congress has
the ability to set its own pay so it's
basically the effective practice of term
limits without having to amend the
Constitution Carlson will follow closely
and thanks for coming in thanks for
having me on Bret